espero que a esta altura tengamos un
buen conocimiento de la distribución de
muestreo de la media de la muestra y lo
que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
explorar un poquito más acerca de cómo
esta distribución cambia conforme vamos
cambiando el tamaño de nuestra muestra
m/m nuestro tamaño de la muestra tenemos
aquí una distribución loca que puede
tener cualquier forma que se nos ocurra
una distribución discreta normalmente
cuando estamos modelando cualquier cosa
va a llegar un momento en el que vamos a
tener que hacer la discreta y esto es
claramente una distribución diferente a
la normal y lo que vimos en el primer
vídeo fue que si tenemos nuestro tamaño
de la muestra digamos que igual a 44
números aleatorios y bueno aquí tenemos
las probabilidades
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 y tomamos 4 números a
la vez le sacamos un promedio que vamos
a hacer esto aquí 4 números a la vez
vamos a imaginar que tomamos esa
distribución para generar estos 4
números aleatorios vemos que es muy
probable que tengamos un 9
definitivamente no vamos a tener ningún
8 7 tampoco un 4 podríamos tener algún 1
o 2 es más probable que tengamos algún 3
o un 5 así que usamos esta función para
generar nuestros números aleatorios
tomamos muestras de 4 y encontramos el
promedio de ellas digamos que nuestro
primer muestreo va a ser de 9 5 9 y un
19 591 entre 4 el promedio de esta
distribución de nuestra primera muestra
es 6 así que ponemos aquí abajo la
gráfica de nuestro promedio 6 y vamos a
seguir haciendo esto vimos en el pasado
que si seguimos haciendo esto comenzará
a veces algo como esto muy parecido a
una distribución normal lo hicimos una
vez el promedio fue 6 aquí el promedio
fue 5 lo volvimos a hacer ahora el
promedio fue 7 una vez más y el promedio
fue 6 y si hacemos esto muchas veces
nuestra distribución lucirá muy parecida
a una distribución normal más o menos
así cada puntito es una de estas pruebas
que hemos hecho así que todas esas
pruebas pueden verse así y bueno no será
una distribución normal perfecta porque
tenemos unos promedios que no pueden ser
menores a 1 o mayores que 9 así que no
tendrá unas causas infinitamente largas
pero al menos la parte central de esta
distribución será muy parecida a la de
la distribución normal en este vídeo lo
que quiero que reflexionemos es qué
sucede cuando cambiamos cuando cambiamos
n el número de las muestras en este caso
teníamos cuatro elementos de muestra
cada vez que hacemos una muestra tomamos
cuatro elementos aleatorios de esta
distribución calculamos el promedio y lo
dibujamos puede haber tenido una n igual
a 10 y obtener 10 muestras de esta
función de distribución obtener el
promedio y dibujarlo aquí
el vídeo anterior o que vimos y vamos a
regresar a esta simulación en un momento
fueron un par de cosas que vamos a ver
con un poco más de profundidad en esta
ocasión cuando eres muy pequeña no se
aproxima tanto a una distribución normal
cuando n es pequeña veamos un caso
extremo cuando en es igual a 1 qué va a
pasar aquí bueno yo voy a tener un valor
de toda esta función de distribución y
voy a tomar el promedio finalmente va a
ser el mismo valor que tomé yo de aquí y
esto está claro que no va a tener forma
de una distribución normal cuando yo
grafique esos promedios se verá que a lo
mejor tengo aquí dos unos unos cuantos
más dos más cantidades de 3 no vamos a
tener ningún 4 vamos a tener bastante 5
y 6 es quizás y un bastantes nueves así
que la distribución de muestreo de la
media de la muestra cuando en es igual a
1 no tiene nada que ver con una
distribución normal y aunque el teorema
del límite central cuando se toman
muchas muestras les comenté que se
parecía mucho a la normal esto no aplica
cuando el tamaño de la muestra es igual
a 1 si tenemos en igualados
bueno lo estoy haciendo en mi cabeza yo
no sé cómo voy a lucir la distribución
en realidad pero aún así sería difícil
obtener la forma de una distribución
normal pero se podría obtener más
variedad de lo que está arriba aunque
solo podríamos tener dos valores de
muestra y el promedio pues no sería tan
variado por ejemplo nunca van a obtener
el siete y media cuando el tamaño de
nuestra muestra es de dos porque nunca
vamos a obtener valores siete y ocho
aquí por lo que nunca vamos a obtener el
valor del promedio de 7.5
así que a lo mejor sí dibujamos esta
distribución cuando en es igual a 2
podría haber sido de más o menos algo
así
con algún hueco en el valor de 7.5
así que no será aún una distribución
normal
aquí hay un par de cosas interesantes
que no he mencionado aún porque primero
quiero que tengamos una buena intuición
en lo que se refiere a este teorema el
problema del límite central nos dice que
conforme n se aproxima al infinito
entonces es cuando obtenemos una
distribución normal real distribución
normal en la práctica cotidiana no
tienen que tener una n tan grande no
tiene que estar tan lejos de esas n1 y
n2 por ejemplo si ustedes tienen una n
igual a 10 pueden tener una muy buena
aproximación a una distribución normal y
otra cosa que se quiere tener es muchas
iteraciones esta n es el tamaño de
nuestra muestra tamaño de la muestra
y en el primer vídeo que hicimos al
respecto tomamos una muestra de tamaño 4
y conforme esta se aproxima al infinito
nuestra distribución de la media de la
muestra se aproxima a una distribución
normal y para demostrar que esto sucede
si si tienen que tomar muchas veces este
número de muestras y sacar su promedio y
graficar lo para ver que efectivamente
va a tener esta distribución recuerden
que la distribución normal esta parte de
aquí es la que tiene toda la población
donde se encuentran todas las
posibilidades en la vida real muy pocas
veces conocemos todas las posibilidades
muy pocas veces sabemos en la vida real
cuál es la función pura generadora de
probabilidades normalmente lo que se
hace es tomar muestras y tratar de
estimar las probabilidades
normalmente cuando hay una variable
aleatoria tomamos un grupo de muestras
encontramos su media y las gráfica moss
y obtenemos una distribución normal
digamos que el también de nuestra
muestra es de 100 y obtenemos su
promedio
esta es la distribución que vamos a
obtener y en teoría conforme vamos
obteniendo estos promedios cientos o
miles de veces nuestro conjunto de datos
va a aproximarse mucho más a la
distribución de muestreo de la media de
la muestra
y esto de aquí es una distribución real
es una distribución real con una media
real y es una media pura la media de la
distribución de muestreo de la media de
la muestra que se escribe así
esto se refiere a la media de la
población real ésta es la media real de
la población la media de una variable
aleatoria real si viéramos todas las
posibilidades de todas las muestras
tomadas de nuestra distribución original
y tomáramos todas las posibilidades de
un tamaño de muestreo digamos igual a 10
todas las combinaciones de las 10
muestras de una distribución original al
obtener el promedio esto describiría esa
función por supuesto si en la realidad
nosotros no sabemos cuál es la
distribución original y pudiéramos hacer
esto un número infinito de veces aunque
no tenemos todas las combinaciones
posibles
si repetiremos este proceso unas mil
veces si mil veces tomáramos diez
muestras de esa distribución y
obtuviéramos el promedio y lo graficar
amos si hiciéramos esto mil veces
nuestra distribución resultante quedaría
muy cercana a la distribución normal
ahora lo siguiente que quiero comentar
es bueno sabemos que conforme n se
aproxima al infinito nuestra
distribución será más
a la distribución normal como les dije
anteriormente si tuviéramos una muestra
de 10 elementos sería una muestra muy
buena pero en el vídeo anterior vimos
algo que yo encontré bastante
interesante comienzo con esta
distribución loca de aquí y en la
simulación vimos que cuando n era igual
a 5 calcularemos el promedio y repetimos
estos 10 mil veces la gráfica se veía
más o menos así un poco ancha y cuando
hicimos la simulación para m igual a 10
nuestra gráfica era un poquito más
angosta y no solamente era más normal
qué es lo que nos dice el teorema del
límite central conforme tomamos muestras
más grandes tenía una desviación
estándar más pequeña y una varianza más
pequeña la media va a ser la misma en
ambos casos pero cuando nuestra muestra
es más grande nuestra desviación
estándar se vuelve más pequeña incluso
nuestra desviación estándar se vuelve
más pequeña que la desviación estándar
de nuestra distribución original
vamos a mostrar eso con la simulación
vamos a limpiar todo
y esta simulación es tan buena como
cualquier otra o mejor dicho esta
distribución es tan buena como cualquier
otra lo que quiero mostrarles es que
cuando nuestro tamaño de la muestra es
igual a 2 no va a ser tan bueno vamos a
comparar en igualados con n igual a 16
iniciemos la simulación y primero vemos
que toma en igualados hace el promedio
lo muestra y después viene en igual a 16
toma el promedio y lo grafica ahora
vamos a hacer esto 10.000 veces así que
noten cuando tenemos en igualados aún
cuando lo hicimos 10.000 veces esto no
se aproxima para nada a una distribución
normal y lo pueden ver en los números de
el sesgo y la curtósis tiene un sesgo
positivo es decir que hay una cauda más
larga hacia la derecha y tiene una
curtósis negativa lo que significa que
tiene unas causas más cortas y picos más
pequeños
por otra parte cuando m es igual a 16
cada vez que tomamos 16 muestras de esta
distribución y obtenemos su promedio
cada uno de estos puntos representa uno
de estos promedios y lo hacemos 10.000
veces encontramos que la media es la
misma en ambos casos pero aquí de pronto
vemos que la curtósis es mucho más
pequeña y también el sesgo es más
pequeño por lo que la distribución es
más normal y otra cosa interesante es
que la desviación estándar también es
más pequeña eso está mucho más angosto
que esto de aquí arriba y
definitivamente mucho más angosto que
nuestra distribución original ahora
vamos a limpiar todo de nuevo y bueno me
gusta esta distribución porque es
bastante fuera de lo normal como si
fuera una distribución bimodal y ahora
vamos a tomar un escenario en donde
tenemos una n igual a 16 que es una n
bastante saludable y vamos a tomar otra
con una m igual a 25
ahora vamos a comparar las vamos a hacer
una animación para que veamos más o
menos cómo se comportan además tenemos
la muestra de adn 16 hasta el promedio
lo grafica y ahora se la muestra de n
igual a 25 la promedia y la gráfica y
ahora vamos a repetir todo esto 10.000
veces el milagro de las computadoras
ahora no tenemos algo
estas son aproximaciones bastante buenas
de la distribución normal la muestra de
n igual a 25 es mucho más normal tiene
menos sesgo ligeramente menos sesgo que
la de n igual a 16 y una curtósis
ligeramente más pequeña que el adn igual
a 16 pero noten que con ella igual a 25
la desviación estándar es todavía más
pequeña es más angosta la desviación
estándar aquí es 2.1 y la desviación
estándar acá es 2.6 comentamos al
respecto en el vídeo anterior de que eso
tiene sentido mientras más grande sea
nuestra muestra vamos a tener menos
desviación estándar imagínense un caso
extremo
en lugar de que el tamaño de nuestra
muestra sea 16 ó 25
tengamos una muestra de tamaño de un
millón
si yo tomara un millón de muestras de
esta distribución de acá la media de la
muestra siempre estará mucho más cerca
de la media de la distribución
si yo obtuviera una media promediando un
millón de muestras tendremos un nuevo
estimado de esa media ya que la
probabilidad de que la mayoría de las
muestras caigan en esta parte sería muy
muy baja así que si el tamaño de la
muestra es de un millón por supuesto que
cuando haga el promedio
esos valores van a estar muy cercanos a
la media de la muestra
espero que esto tenga sentido para
ustedes si no es así
usen esta herramienta y experimenten
para que puedan darse cuenta que
realmente ese es el caso y resulta que
existe una fórmula bastante elegante que
relaciona la desviación estándar de la
función de distribución de probabilidad
original con la desviación estándar de
la distribución de muestreo de la media
de la muestra y se pueden imaginar que
es una función del tamaño de la muestra
depende del número de muestras que
ustedes tomen de su distribución
original y eso lo veremos en el
siguiente vídeo